hello and welcome to this video playing
shootin maybe we'll see i'm going to
play commence gambit here and see what
is coming up with just being a super
sound and solid here ever really bad
score against this player one win three
losses surprising okay let's see what
happens I regroup in my bishop here on
the incorrect diagonal for possible
kingside play and see what happens I'm
going to try to slow down his play on
them the come inside little bit with a
five now i'm drawing Bishop g4 trying to
take on f3 is illegal maybe move the
night but then queen age 4 is an option
one drawback of my position is that the
pawn on age 6 is blocking the possible
route e 62 h success as a typical
counter play in this in this kind of
situation and not going to happen here
okay i think inaudible these seven looks
good I need the night there on the King
side
NH 4 immediately was possible of course
but i think i need i need the night as
well ok so the thing is Queen to h4 are
some other move look I'm sorry clean g5
is also interesting i'll create form
provoking a weakness yeah let's provoke
the weakness with g3 ok it's not going
for that night f1 was sensible move also
yeah how to get more firepower than into
the attack we can try try Luke lift sir
let's head but rook to h6 is not on
hmm not so easy to get something good
going here I can I go Knight f6 see from
them yeah I hope that this Bishop is
helping to protect the sixth and I've
got 94 coming to provoke and to provoke
a three fish about five know is a good
move but this is a tough move to play
okay I'm so Nyjah form and it's got
Knight b6 coming here maybe taking on a
four and then 94 actually hmm
now it's probably not enough I can do
this it's interesting I strange III have
forgot about that about that immediate
possibility
hmm I was stupid now he's got 96 coming
up
between f6 sh3 unfortunately
now probably can just take here and take
this 6 don't see you see something good
here
Joe not a good game not a good game I
didn't play that good well didn't play
that well
pretty bad f3 is also a threat time
morning geez
and now is playing genius moves great
stuff so really no way here to get
something hanuman should be seven maybe
that wasn't even that great no way this
is unprotected unbelievable
Jim no idea what I did wrong in this
game
good no scratch or clap resins keep the
night to keep that protective I have no
idea I mean I don't think I'm Lucia
that's that's hard to believe but what
what did I do wrong yeah maybe the
timing there with this 94 was off that
it's possible the computer wants me to
take with the bishop nap Wow
over that is also better for white if I
have to take with the bishop here now
yeah I'm worse I mean I'm really worse
that is not working at all I mean this
is just straight straight losing and he
played them the are played at 35 assists
of course accelerating things but it's
just a lost position so huh what did
what went wrong here that's just a very
normal position and I don't think I can
be substantially worse iam yeah maybe
this isn't so great huh no engine wants
to play this what should I actually
spend the time and play b5 here I mean
this is definitely possible
and that looks better i'll probably have
to do this I mean here that also cannot
be so bad maybe night maybe maybe his
balance to this and after b5 now if now
play something else
no maybe it's still equally sure but I
think b5 is probably better just
shutting down the whole thing here
before I even go clean edge for once the
best the best moment to do it probably
and try try for this that should be
reasonable to be reasonable position one
thing that I had planned was this but it
is unfortunately not working at all as
he has g3 yet covers both it's not
working at all as this here I'm just
lost him but just loses it sir its
opponent the whole structure goes goes
down the drain yeah maybe have to play
that b5 move I mean probably not um it's
not like the only rules but maybe it's
really what what I should do I mean this
is sometimes also recipe against the
minority a check to do this not sure
about this yet it might not be the best
way to do it now I think be five is good
and I should do this just stop the b5
advance probably about equal the way it
went it wasn't it wasn't good and even
finish this very convincingly I guess
then all of a sudden oops I cannot move
my bishop yeah and here well it's just
two points and to know what take what
Sam
Wow very nicely played thanks for
watching